je je viens en savoie en savoie quand
c'est l'hiver on skie le mercredi le
samedi et le dimanche
et quand c'est les vacances en ski tous
les jours on skie avec les parents avec
les copains avec les cousins ou avec le
ski club
le problème c'est que j'aime pas le ski
on m'a forcé plusieurs années et puis on
m'a désinscrit du cycle ma famille était
catastrophée comment allait-on occupée
on m'a fait essayer le judo la gym la
danse le tennis pas de chance j'aime pas
non plus alors on m'a plu inscrit à rien
enfin j'avais du temps moi mon bébé m'a
offert une boîte à outils mon pépé c'est
l'expert des cadeaux bizarre dans la
boîte il y avait un marteau une si un
cutter et une personne ma mère faisait
une drôle de tête
moi j'étais ravie
à ce moment là dans mon école le maître
maîtresses voulait encourager les
enfants à venir
j'ai proposé que l'on transforme la
bibliothèque en s capron vous connaissez
c'est une thèse dans laquelle on vous
enferme avec des amis et vous devez
trouver des indices et résoudre des
énigmes pour cela il faut être malin
lire et ça c'est sûr ça donnera envie
aux enfants de venir
mais bon la bibliothèque n'était pas
prête
les maîtresses boucle je suis parti
quinze jours à la campagne avec mes
grands parents
là bas il n'ya pas la télé il n'y a pas
internet
alors on en profite pour jouer dehors
mais bon il a plu tous les jours alors
on est restés dedans
j'avais amené mon cartable pour avancer
mes devoirs et je me suis dit et si je
rendais les devoirs
amusant au lieu de sortir du mythe cesse
il faudrait rentrer dans le cartable
fermée à clé alors j'ai fait ça il faut
compter les points sur chaque brique
lego les mettre dans l'ordre du plus
petit au plus grand et ensuite rentrer
le code sur le canal
je lui ai donné en mystérieuse cartable
moitié français moitié en anglais car
mon école est bilingue
gfr un logo moitié cartable moitié cana
et j'ai fait un slogan le sale escape
game dans un cartable
quand je suis rentré de vacances j'ai
fait jouer mon cartable aux maîtres et
maîtresses ils ont bien aimé alors ils
ont fait un planning et pendant les
récrés je faisais jouer les élèves dans
la salle des profs et ils ont adoré
mais pour faire jouer plus d'élèves
il me fallait plus de fournitures
scolaires alors je suis allé voir ma
peine
c'est une très grande entreprise qui
fabrique plein de fournitures scolaires
6 euros et on trouve du coup je leur ai
fait jouer le cartable et ils ont adoré
alors ils m'ont donné plein de
fournitures scolaires pour faire
d'autres cartes mais pour faire un
cartable futur x il me fallait codé
alors je suis allé voir
stmicroelectronics c'est une entreprise
qui fabrique des tout petits capteurs
comme dans les téléphones
voilà ensuite je suis allé à station f
c'est un incubateur comme dans pokémon
go où l'on doit faire grandir mais là on
fait grandir son projet et il a bien
grandi maintenant une mystérieuse
cartable c'est toute une collection
il y a confisqué à tort futur x o my dog
le génie du grenier et l'original j'ai
fait des conférences en france ou à
l'étranger
j'ai gagné des prix et j'ai rencontré
plein de gens me voient là un an plus
tard mon cartable à bien voyager
et moi aussi je vis toujours en savoie
et l'hiver arrive et j'irai peut-être je
dis bien peut-être faire un petit peu de
ski
surtout je continue à bricoler et mes
copines aussi s'y mettent
le bricolage c'est devenu une activité à
la mode et ensemble c'est sûr on va la
faire cette escape room dans la
bibliothèque
merci
[Applaudissements]